so I got this other thing that's trended
this week There's a you know how I've
talked about this before on my channel
where women like to broadcast their
failures in life it usually happens on
Tick Tock and often in their cars or in
some you know bizarre
scenario oh like you know this is a guy
that I dated like there was one that I
posted on my uh entrepreneurs and cars
Channel basically a lady that was
traveling around and she was in Tulum at
the time she dated a guy four times they
smashed and then he ghosted her and
she's like oh well onwards and upwards
to find the next guy and it's like
there's this archive there's this like
encyclopedia library on her timeline of
all the guys that she spent time with
and that's just what they do now there's
another Trend where people are
complaining about their relationships
um in single moms uh like to get picked
up on this so I want to throw this up on
the uh the screen and we can provide
some commentary on it but
I did a video here just let me know if
you guys can hear this oh God yeah
thousand Cox there yeah they all have it
can you guys following my lives I've
been halfway considering is the audio
coming coming through yes I can hear it
yeah you can hear it okay so
this is the soul Crusher 3000 this is it
could be the soul Crusher 8000 to 2000
but this is what a lot of dudes fall for
on dating apps is you know like the
pretty face the hair the makeup you can
tell that she was way hotter when she
was younger you know she looks pissed
off though already
oh yeah she's got RBF you know like this
is like still Smasher
oh yeah yeah definitely of course you
would
of course
I had a crazy chick come over the other
day that shit's terrifying once you
realize like oh she's not mentally there
she can't we can't can't take a thought
actually actually play it
it's actually kind of unnerving you get
to a point you're like all right I I
don't even want you here in my presence
anymore and then it was kind of like how
do I get her out of here without having
her flipper lid all right so 50 just
joined what's up 50. um so let's play
this and see what our single mommy has
to say about her choices in life
all right y'all I'm ready for everyone
to say I told you so
so if you've been following my lives
I've been halfway considering moving
back in with my kids sad
I know I know I know
I know needless to say we've been
looking at places we were actually
getting ready to sign a place
foreign
[Music]
I know I know it's stupid okay I know
it's stupid but I'm literally [__]
drowning I'm [__] drowning he does
not help me with these children he does
not help me he thinks if he sends me a
couple hundred bucks a month that it
like somehow makes him a co-parent
whenever these kids have been out of
school like 80 of the month because of
sickness and [__] so like I'm drowning
let me just pause for just one quick
second I've been parenting for quite a
few years now and at no time has my kid
ever been out of school for 80 of a
month due to a sickness you've got to be
a shit-ass parent if your kids are out
of school 80 of the month just saying
and the only way I can see that I can
actually get help from him is if I force
him into a house with me
and then we can go [__] half
it to it but like obviously obviously oh
my god well the [__] made boy
said that he was done with that [__]
he said he was done
guess who [__] adds me on Snapchat
this morning
that [__] that hard
all to tell me that he's been on her
line
so I confirm about it because that's not
what I signed up for I obviously didn't
sign up for us to be together obviously
immediately but women women have a way
of like tracking down other women and
making themselves known don't they like
guys on the panel could you imagine your
mom's like I know we're we're older and
thank God they didn't have this
technology around but I grew up in the
90s or like Rich drugs you know 70s 80s
whenever you guys grew up could you
imagine your mom's doing this if the
technology is available how embarrassed
you would be as a kid I would no wonder
her kids are out of school I'd never
show my face at school my mom was
posting this [__] online yeah basically
I was in the back of my head if we're
signing up to get a house together in
the same room together in the same bed
together and you say that you're done
with her obviously that's on my mind
that we're working on [__] right right
okay whatever so I rip him the shreds
well I'm getting receipts I'm literally
getting receipts I can see the stupid
[__] he's a dumb [__] he's a dumb [__]
she's a dumb [__] I'm so done I'm so
done
she's not done for choosing this guy
I mean yeah not her fault you know it's
not her fault for letting him nut in her
like twice clearly
nothing's got anything to do with being
her fault right
I'm not too [__] Ground Zero except
for the fact I literally I need to be
out of my house I need to be out of my
house in like less than a month
we are busting out of the seams there I
have I I I
need help I need I need an arranged
marriage that's where I'm at I'm looking
for an arranged marriage at this point I
can cook I can clean I can throw it back
for you like
you're getting some great kids you're
getting some free animals you're getting
free kids and free animals like this is
part of her sales I can cook I can
exactly still can throw my back out for
you you're getting these kids you're
getting free animals
and all this drama that she's bringing
to the table in her car right now I'm
wondering what the warranty would be
like on that on that there is no
warranty warranty is expired there are
700 000 miles on the clock and nobody
wants the vehicle
it's retitled it's a retitled vehicle
title salvage title
this is a bad situation this is nothing
but an infomercial that's all she's
looking for she just wants to put it out
there that you're going to get a bratty
girl who's good-looking
semi-good-looking and you just want to
be taken care of and you know it'll be
rinse and repeat five years down the
road the same video will pop up again
but wait wait look at that but wait for
the comments there's still another 50
seconds hold on I will go half season
with you on bills like I just don't care
at this point I am willing and able to
sign my arranged marriage just like
just help me a little bit please please
please go half season with me on bills
please
be a step daddy don't touch my kids
please now I talked about this in my
book when I was covering the segment on
single moms and why guys shouldn't date
single moms again let me get that clear
should not date single moms you will
have responsibility to their children
but not have any authority over them as
a parent
she just said that in different words
please take care of me please take care
of my kids but don't touch them
now
this is this is the reality but let's
keep going like just just
serve me please I'll take care of you
like you know like
you're so desperate and this is I am so
mad that this is the point that I'm at
this is not the point that I should be
at but this is the point I'm out because
our dad is stupid yeah he's a stupid hoe
so over I'm so
freaking and you're right once again I
love this for me I love this for me at
least I didn't actually do it at least
before I signed but
but I need to move
I need help [__] me yeah she's acting
like I'm ready some kind of win that she
that she figured this out before she
signed anything but you've already got
two of his kids lady
let's see what the comments say here
yeah I was gonna say because you're
going to see guys like oh honey I'll
make you mine in little heart faces or
so Sarah says why do you all assume she
is in the wrong all by herself well
where where is the accountability where
is the ownership that she's taking she's
so sad to me another story of a man who
didn't step up for his kids yeah the
guy's a loser of course it's always got
to do with the father this is what men
leave in their wake when they refuse to
grow up it's again it's all the man's
fault is is there any ownership or is it
any accountability what is this woman
like to live with because in this two
minute and 55 second clip look at look
at her eyes
in this clip she's miserable as [__] I
would run her face when she conceived
sorry sorry go ahead big black oh well I
was just saying that like the the
Tantrum the way that she's talking it's
the way that a teenager talks Brad right
you know it's the way that a kid talks
you know kid just stopping their feet at
having to babysit other kids you know
like when she wants to go out with her
friends like do you know what I mean
like it seems like a teenager being
forced to babysit their little siblings
and and throwing a tantrum about it if
uh if a red flag could talk yeah yeah
the comments are actually hella funny
yeah
it makes more sense when you skip right
to the end yeah
you know what the single use I see for
this type of relationship or for having
a relationship with this type of person
if you're one of the kind of people that
loses weight when they're stressed
and you want to introduce some stress in
your life so that you lose some weight
oil instant stress
this is interesting new hair new teeth
eyebrows done no money left over for the
kids very very astute observation by our
friend Brett right she's complaining
about not having any money but her hair
is clearly just done
that is a recent hairdo for sure
anyway you guys get the point clip if
you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out